perth c'est à capital de la maison en
terre un peu partout dans la ville on
peut voir des bâtiments construits avec
ce matériau
comme ce pavillon en bord de mer
[Musique]
où cette grande maison familiale
ou bien encore ce petit immeuble de
centre ville
c'est aussi le cas d'école de bureau ou
de centres commerciaux comme celui ci au
total plusieurs centaines de maisons en
terre sont disséminés dans la région de
perth et ce n'est pas un hasard car
c'est ici que vit le plus gros
constructeur de ce type de maison en
australie
stéphane dobson 63 ans
la première maison en terre qu'il a
construite à perth c'est la sienne salut
chérie tu as passé une bonne journée
c'était en 1980 stephen et sa femme
hélène ont voulu une maison spacieuse
avec tout le confort moderne
l'intérieur garde par exemple une
températures toujours agréables même en
plein été grâce au rôle de climatiseur
naturel joué par la terre
à l'époque ils ont conçu leur habitation
comme un prototype de plusieurs
techniques
ma maison était la première en terre
dans la région j'ai pu me permettre
d'expérimenter plein de choses on a
construit par exemple un garde manger
avec un toit voûtée en terre on a aussi
essayé des fondations terre c'était la
première fois qu'on tenter des
expériences pareil pour une maison en
pleine ville mais comme c'était ma
maison si jamais il y avait un problème
ça n'était pas grave c'est donc en
tâtonnant que stephen dobson a fini par
mettre au point cette maison idéale au
départ sa vocation est née à la suite
d'une catastrophe
en
1974 le cyclone tracy détruit 80 % d'une
petite ville au nord de l'australie
stephen dobson jeunes ingénieurs fait
partie de la commission de
reconstruction
reconstruire en béton coûte cher il n'ya
pas non plus de forêt autour pour
rebâtir en bois alors il a l'idée
d'utiliser la terre il réalise des tests
de solidité car les nouveaux bâtiments
devront pouvoir résister aux futurs
cyclone
finalement son projet n'est pas retenu
par la ville
mais pour stephen dobson c'est le début
d'une passion et d'une carrière
son vrai décollage il le doit un coup de
pouce inespéré
il a réussi à imposer la terre dans
l'esprit des australiens grâce à une
première commande pour une maison très
spécial et il tient nous l'a montré
direction le sud à 3h de perth
une cote paradisiaque où se trouve une
station balnéaire chic margaret river
nous arrivons près du bâtiment que
stephen va nous faire visiter c'est bien
d'une maison mais pas celle de n'importe
qui
voilà c'est une maison un peu spéciale
mais celle de dieu sait vraiment ce
bâtiment qui a fait exister la maison en
terre sur la carte de l'australie
prouver aux gens que la terre était un
matériau aussi valable qu'un autre à
l'époque c'était le plus grand bâtiment
en terre jamais construit en australie
ce fameux bâtiment c'est l'église de
saint thomas more dieu a donc été le
premier client de stephen dobson ou plus
exactement le curé de la paroisse
construit par des fidèles volontaires en
1981 cette église a immédiatement
suscité un engouement dans la région
et stephen est plutôt fier de son coup
il ne pouvait pas rêver meilleure carte
de visite
vous allez me dire cette église je m'en
sert comme d'un outil marketing oui
c'est vrai c'est du marketing mais pour
la bonne cause et les gens sont venus de
partout pour voir cette église et ils
disaient nous aussi on va se faire
construire une maison en terre
depuis stephen dobson a construit des
centaines de maisons dans tout le pays
et même 30 ans après ils découvrent
encore de nouveaux avantages à bâtir en
terre comme il va s'en apercevoir sur le
chemin du retour
la région était ravagé par un incendie
stephen est consterné je croirais sur la
lune ou sur mars on dirait un paysage
extraterrestre j'ai jamais vu ça comme
ça avant c'est vraiment un sacré choc
dans certaines zones les villas ont été
complètement rasée par les flammes mais
stephen remarque vite que ce n'est pas
le cas de toutes les maisons
[Musique]
c'est intéressant de voir que les
maisons en terre ont été protégés du feu
je vais prendre des photos
en effet cette résidence secondaire en
acier et en bois a été détruite par
l'incendié
[Musique]
en revanche les constructions en terre
comme ce mur on était à peine noircie
par les flammes
quant à la maison voisine 50 mètres plus
loin une maison en terre construit par
stephen elle a été épargnée
dans un pays où les feux de brousse sont
fréquents c'est un nouvel argument qu'il
espère bien faire valoir
c'est quand même une situation assez
incroyable il y a deux maisons en terre
intacte et juste à côté une maison en
bois et en acier complètement détruite
incendie ça va clairement nous faire une
bonne pub
on a de la chance de pouvoir prendre ça
en photos maintenant parce que si on
était venu dans quelques semaines tout
aurait été nettoyées on dirait plus rien
de tout ça et il aurait déjà une
nouvelle maison à la place
jolie maison résistante au feu et
surtout qui ne coûte pas plus cher que
des habitations en béton mais pour y
arriver stephen dobson un secret de
fabrication
nous allons le découvrir sur un chantier
à une heure du centre ville de perth en
plein milieu de la forêt
et henry gray oui ce que je gare ma
voiture
ici il construit un centre de yoga et
pour faire baisser les prix stephen a
réussi à gagner du temps sur une étape
clé
il a inventé un système rapide de
coffrage qu'il a breveté
ces plaques se montent et se démontent
comme un meccano elles permettent à ces
ouvriers de monter un mur beaucoup plus
vite
ensuite il n'y a plus qu'à tasser la
terre et le tour est joué
problème en france c'est que vous n'avez
pas d'ouvriers spécialisés dans la
construction en terre
en australie on en a c'est qu'elles ne
font que ça et puis chez nous c'est une
industrie qui a déjà 30 ans un bail
c'est toutes ces petites choses combinés
ensemble qui font que ça marche bien ici
mais pour arriver à construire avec ce
matériau naturel stephen a surtout dû
faire une entorse à ses principes écolo
car dans cette terre récupérée sur place
il n'y a pas assez d'argent il un lien
naturel pour solidifier le mur alors il
a fait rajouter un ingrédient que l'on
connaît bien du ciment
de mon point de vue l'idéal bien sûr
c'est de ne pas mettre de ciment
nous si on en met c'est parce que c'est
plus rapide ces poulets facile et c'est
moins cher
et si vous en utilisez trop peu le mur
ne sera pas assez solide avec la terre
qu'on a ici ce qui peut être évidemment
dangereux
certes la maison ainsi construite en
australie mais pas 100 % écolo les une
chose est sûre stephen aura tout de même
utiliser moitié moins de six mots qu'il
n'en faut pour un palier en béton et en
se servant de la terre il aura aussi
éviter de puiser des tonnes de sable
dans l'environnement
rêve de bâtir des maisons en terre plus
écolo et moins chère semble donc à notre
portée